pulling the trigger at the pump is a
painful business
particularly if your business is driving
it's just getting to a point where is it
worth it anymore it's just well i'm
taking no wages out at the minute i'm
funding the extra field costs
paul has a council contract to transport
disabled children to school but the fuel
price was set in 2019 so he loses money
on every mile even allowing for the 5p
cut in fuel duty announced by the
chancellor no it won't make no
difference whatsoever but every little
helps it'd have to be 20 30 40p
a liter to help save three months ago i
was probably paying one pound seventeen
one pound eighteen a liter now it's gone
up to just locally 182 nearly 183 litre
and obviously 10 vehicles using between
60 and 80 liters a week
becomes expensive
keeping production lines moving has got
more expensive too there's no energy
price cap for business and no new
measures to help companies like this
packaging manufacturer
in the modern economy everything from
eggs to engines comes in a box so price
rises here will be delivered to our
doors one way or another energy bills
are around seven thousand pound a month
we're fixed until mid 2023
that's seven thousand goes to eighteen
thousand and we're one of the lower
energy consumers within the supply chain
with inflation at a 30-year high of 6.2
percent even before russia invaded
ukraine worse is to come what makes
energy and fuel inflation so pernicious
is it affects the price of everything
from raw materials to transport even the
pallets goods are loaded on it's almost
inevitable manufacturers have to pass on
these costs to consumers there's very
little the chancellor can do about it
food price inflation may see the
steepest increase of all iceland has 1
000 stores many in the least prosperous
communities the boss says the chancellor
should have done more to insulate his
business and his customers
business is not some endless sponge that
can forever soak this stuff up we talk
rightly about the consumer and i think
that's important but also the government
needs to protect business as well
because ultimately it's the consumer
that pays for it so
what i would have liked to have seen was
a a price cap on energy for business
rebuilding the economy after kobit was
never going to be straight forward
businesses face the hardest year yet
knowing they'll have to stand or fall
alone for kelso sky news in
staffordshire